I could call five people on the phone
right now who have been tortured by the
Russians this is my fifth war zone six
if you include Congress comes in on a
day five I think you said of the full
scale Invasion no boxes there from the
Red Cross from the UN the big
International organizations you would
expect to be effective in a in in a
situation like this were not there's
propagandist in America hey Tucker how
much money is enough people in the
United States don't understand how how
bad things are that the Russians are
trying to make you crazy in March of
2022 nobody was partying nobody's really
talking about the elections in Ukraine
right now how do you feel about the
upcoming US elections yeah how many
shahad drones did proor and Campbell buy
when you see big corruption make noise
is an opportunity to live into one of my
core values of Freedom H capucino
Zas hi everyone you're watching Ukraine
or English Channel and this is the
series series Ukraine Through The Eyes
of others where we talk with different
political experts academics journalists
about Ukraine and the Russian war
against it and today we're joined by
Steven Moore a political strategist
International social entrepreneur
political opinion researcher with an
experience in more than a dozen
countries he spent seven years as a
chief of staff in a senior leadership
Aid in the United States Congress and
he's considered one of the most powerful
behind the scenes voices in The GOP
circles welcome Stephen thank you so
much for joining us wow thanks for that
kind introduction I tried yeah that
guy's cool I want to meet that guy I
mean we're meeting him here thank you so
much for coming today in ke um well
you're from Tulsa Oklahoma I've actually
been to Tulsa you've been to Tulsa I've
been to Tulsa you know I can tell by
your accent yeah it's I got my accent
from Louisiana United States uh where I
spent my exchange year um in
20156 and I don't remember much from my
short weekend trip from SHP for
Louisiana to Tulsa Oklahoma but but I
remember that it's very different from
Ukraine and as somebody who went all the
way from Kio to Tulsa Oklahoma I'm
really curious how you went the same way
but in the opposite direction um yeah
well I grew up in Oklahoma and it's
funny I brought a Ukrainian to Tulsa and
she said the opposite of what she said
you said she said Tulsa Oklahoma is so
much like Ukraine and you know I think
it's like the the fields and the
Agriculture and it's you know it's kind
of flat and and uh the summer was hot
like today so um so I'm interested
that's that's that's funny and what what
did you do in Tulsa I think I just
visited around I don't remember much
because it was more than eight years ago
and I was there only for like maybe two
three days okay but I remember going
around the city and like visiting a
local high school because my friend went
to high school there so ah okay yeah the
reason I said it was different because I
think the just overall the I think
mentality the overview of people on the
world seemed very different to me at
that time specifically in the American
South yeah yeah no I would agree you
know keev is a very Cosmopolitan City
tuls Oklahoma is a great Regional City
and it's a great place to grow up um and
uh I I left Oklahoma a long time ago and
my mom still lives there so the question
was how do I get to Ukraine yes um you
know I lived here in 2018 and 2019 and
loved it it was a great place you know
the the energy here is so different than
any place else I've been and I've been
to 60 countries so um you know the
Ukrainian people are entrepreneurial
they're creative they're Innovative um
there's all these cool Brands I mean
look at you guys you got Ukraine or you
got this is cool look at that t-shirt so
um you know it it's it's people here the
culture is real and you know in America
in contrast you know we've got big
Blockbuster films like this Barbie film
right it was like it was made with focus
groups
and and so it's manufactured culture and
in Ukraine the culture is
real wow I never thought about it in
that way but um uh it's really Pleasant
to hear you also have an organization
that is called the Ukraine Freedom
project that's correct um and you've
delivered more than aill million dollar
worth of Aid to different parts of
Ukraine including the front line towns
um I was curious how someone like you
who's a a foreigner comes in on a day
five I think you said of the fulls scale
Invasion and sets up an NGO that is both
um I guess far-reaching and effective
here what are the challenges maybe that
you've faced well when I came here the
bar was low uh so um you know I came
here and Di for of the war um I had a
bunch of friends in Ukraine and you know
I'm calling them and saying are you okay
and they're saying things like they're
bombing keev I don't know what to do and
I had spent nearly two years as a
civilian in Iraq during the beginning of
that war this is um this is my fifth war
zone six if you include Congress and um
so I knew what to do you know so so I
just came here and started trying to
help my friends get a hot spots like
keev and harv places like that and then
what I found was that the big
International organizations you would
expect to be effective in a in in a
situation like this were not um you know
the the so after about three weeks all
my friends that wanted to be safe were
safe so I'm thinking what do I do now do
I just like declare Victory and go home
and uh and then a friend of a friend
called me from Bita you know where that
is it's a little village um outside of
ke kind of South of the Joma Road um and
he says you I'm trying to help these
folks in this Clinic it's a small Clinic
not set up Tick War wounded yet we are
can you help me get medical supplies and
I said um you know I don't want to go to
the
front you know call the Red Cross and
he's like who and so uh I ended up
putting about $6,000 with medical
supplies on my credit card this is
before we started raising money and uh
driving them you know up here and and
sure enough there was no boxes there
from the Red Cross from the UN from you
know all the boxes were like from you
know St Mary's Church and Lancaster
Pennsylvania you know and that sort of
thing right um so uh so I I recognized
there was a need and I tried to help
fill it and that's kind of what I've
been doing so far since I've been here
is is what are the hard problems to
solve because I have a network in
Washington DC and around the world how
can I bring that Network to bear on the
problems here in Ukraine so that's what
I'm doing wow that sounds pretty cool
thank you so much for doing that that
and in terms of fundraising because you
said that you first started putting your
own money and then started to fundraise
who are your top donors is it like a big
people who put a lot of cash up front or
is it actually Grassroots people in the
United States there's there's a few
people that you may have heard of but
mostly um you know my friend Brian is a
big donor thanks Brian yeah yeah Brian
America Sacramento California um uh
Terry and Laura Haynes uh Brian Gaston
and if there's I've got a thousand
donors so I'm going to get in trouble
here by you know naming specific people
and it would take a long time so uh but
just people I know who are good-hearted
and want to see Ukraine win and um and a
lot of my friends would like to be here
you know I mean people at the beginning
of the war called me dude I would so
much love to be there with you but you
know my wife my kids mortgage you know
so I was just in a really fortunate
position where a lot of things came
together that I could come and help were
they interested in Ukraine before or did
this um no you know I mean yes and no
some of them somewhat but um mostly
they're interested in Freedom
and you know a lot of my friends on
Capitol Hill got into the politics
business because you
know they value Freedom it's one you
know it's one of my core values uh and
as an example you know I mentioned I was
in Iraq for two years I was in um uh I
was in Muslim countries for about three
and a half years following September
11th 2001 because I wanted to try to see
if I could help the the Muslim World
figure out how to solve their problems
with words rather than guns and bombs
and uh so after I was done with that I
got the Arabic word for freedom tattooed
on my calf and uh so um yeah so being
here in Ukraine is an opportunity to
live into one of my core values of
freedom and there's a lot of people
people in the United States that share
that value so now I guess you need the
Ukrainian award for Freedom you good
tattoo artist I can recommend you a you
here how many tattoos do you have I have
only one it's actually it's an Ukrainian
as well it's here you can see it but um
it's a Ukrainian poet who speaks about
uh um who says if only you knew how
beautiful you are when you have no fear
within you and I actually got it toed
after thek Invasion because it's very
metaphorical in way I love that that's
awesome who's who's the poet uh isri
okay yes um so here in Ukraine we also
have series called de occupation where
our team goes to recently liberated or
as we say de occupied areas of UC of
Ukraine and talk to different people
Gathering stories of resistance uh
talking to people who did everything
from the smallest to the most Brave acts
of courage to make sure that the Russian
occupiers feel unwelcomed here I know
that you've been through uh many places
in Ukraine what are some stories that
may be stuck with you you know I have a
friend Dennis okay when I was here in
2019 Dennis was my trainer at the gym
and super cool guy just just you know
big lovable caring guy and super fun
and he was actually the guy that picked
me up at the border whenever I came in
cuz I was
like it's like you know he had been in
Don boss in 2014 so I was like you know
he knows which end of an AK-47 works
right and so I said Dennis you know I'm
in Romania just outside chipy can you
come get me so Dennis came got me we
started working together to get people
out um we started working together uh
with the key of territorial defense um
and he became a a very effective part of
that force and then uh he ended up um
he's he is uh you know in the Ukrainian
Special Forces and you know he's been
wounded twice and uh he keeps going back
and uh you know he's just an amazing
human being because he maintains his
he's seen and done horrible things and
uh because he's had to and you know he
maintains his sense of humor and he's
just you know good energy guy despite
what's happened to him people in the
United States don't understand how bad
things are in Ukraine and I tell them
it's you know so Ukraine is better than
you think and it's worse than you think
because you know keev is a highly
functioning City and we're in keev right
now and it's a nice place to be um which
is good right because in in March of
last year I was here and it wasn't like
this there was hedgehogs everywhere
there was checkpoints every 100 meters
and you could hear artillery it was not
a good place to be and uh and now it is
now so Ukraine is better than you think
it's also worse than you think because
um you know you look at places like
saliva or
um you know or Isom or um many of the
places that have been thoroughly
destroyed by the Russians and the
Terrible Things the Russians do like um
people in
America there's propagandists in America
that say things I I heard this thing on
Tucker Carlson you heard Tucker Carlson
of course unfortunately yeah it's my own
will yeah very bad man uh didn't always
it wasn't always but some so there was
this guy he has on his colonel uh
Douglas McGregor McGregor says you know
he's like this Russian apology says no
and the Russians are very gentle with
ukrainians when they capture them you
know and that just blew my mind because
I could call five people on the phone
right now who have been tortured by the
Russians you know so uh your question
was The Bravery of ukrainians
and and the people I know that have been
tortured just kind of take it in stride
yeah they held me in a basement for 3
days and you know
know you know and uh uh what's for
dinner you know so uh the resiliency of
the ukrainians is amazing and the
Innovations and the stuff they're doing
it's amazing it's really amazing to see
somebody like you to actually um get to
see it firsthand and because it's as you
said very important because you have
those firsthand contacts while somebody
who sits at tuer Carlson show um talking
about things that just
I don't know either straight up Russian
propaganda and Russian lies uh which
makes you question like how do those
things get funded who like where where
where that show gets support or just
doesn't understand anything and still
dares to speak on the behalf of
ukrainians themselves yeah Julia um
let's take tur tury Carlson as an
example so um you know you can find the
crimin and prop propagandists saying
something on Tuesday on their shows
Tucker will say it on Wednesday on his
show and then on Thursday the same
Kremlin propagandist will Air a clip
from Tucker Carlson show and so there's
a symbiotic propaganda relationship
there and you know Tucker's worth $400
million so you know hey Tucker how much
money is
enough yeah so it's just it's
mindboggling to me and and I've met tuer
Carlson I worked with him on a project
like 10 or 12 years ago and you know
we're both from San Diego we both have
San Diego ties um I grew up in Tulsa but
I spent a lot of my professional life in
San Diego um we knew some of the same
people and he was really a Charming Man
12 years ago I don't know what happened
to him yeah that's that's a good
question so how do you
think we or maybe you guys in the United
States of America can actually
counteract what comes from Tucker KY cuz
he got a very powerful platform I know
that he doesn't have Fox anymore but
he's back on Twitter and um he's pretty
effective there if you see the reach of
his uh stuff that he puts out if you see
then how then like people react and how
they boost that propaganda what are some
I don't know maybe like ways of
challenging that yeah and that's an
excellent question and um you know and I
think that what I'm finding is that
people in America don't know who to
believe and so people of Goodwill in
America don't have time to come here and
have a look around like I have um and
they uh and the news media in America is
not as trustworthy as it used to be in
any leftwing rightwing anything in the
middle uh nobody trusts the media
anymore so how do you know what the real
story is and you know I think that one
thing for people in America if the
Kremlin is repeating uh you know their
the the newscaster you're watching if
the Kremlin thinks it's a good idea to
watch them they're probably not the
people to watch but I think more
powerfully the people in America who
have a personal experience of Ukraine
are are just on board right they
understand it so um what I'm finding is
that when people like on social media
just Reach Out ukrainians reach out to
Americans that maybe they don't know and
just say you know thank you for your
help you know the the Patriot missiles
keep my family and I safe at night I
just want to say thank you so any way
that ukrainians can say thank you I
think is a good thing to do yeah well
actually I mean they saved us tonight I
don't know if you heard the the the
missiles coming into Kev I don't know if
it was missiles or drones but actually
they um it's I think like my mom woke me
up around like 5:00 a.m. because yeah
because you didn't hear them no I sleep
very well maybe yeah because you have a
very tight sleeve but they also like
they they I think like the debris were
falling around the area where I live so
is that right yeah so thank you so much
for that specifically I think like here
in K we can really feel the difference
between when we didn't have the Patriot
missiles and now that we do we we hear a
lot of obviously the shooting down and
outcoming missile uh but it's not as I
guess scary anymore and more people feel
more safe in this area thanks to Patriot
missiles yeah I I used to work at an
artificial intelligence company called
Data robot which was had about 500
employees here in Ukraine which is yet
another Ukrainian connection for me and
I did the math in uh I guess it was in
like in February you know there's about
four months worth of missiles at that
point so I did the math and uh my
friends in DC were four times more
likely to die in a traffic accident uh
than I was to die from missiles in
Ukraine so um so it's good that people
are not afraid because these are not
military weapons these are not weapons
that are meant to degrade Ukraine's
ability to wage war um these are weapons
to make people afraid and you know and
again in keev I think it was like you're
nine times more likely to die in a
traffic accident than you are from a
missile so if you're really worried
about your own safety don't get in a car
but don't worry about missiles yeah I
mean I I I think it's a still obviously
different psychological um weight uh
when you hear it every night especially
like we did in in May and beginning of
June uh
2023 um because basically Russians were
bumping cave every every night and by
the I was here but yeah by the 20th
night you're like yeah like this is
really depleting my mental health in
ability to kind of think straight
exactly what they're trying to do yeah
and and again the the real danger that's
not the real there's the real danger
does not come in your life every day the
real danger does not come from missiles
they are something that is designed that
the Russians are trying to make you
crazy and so so I admire the people of
Kei and Ukraine more broadly because you
know they're living through this they're
functioning well um you know again we're
here in Kei it's a very highly
functioning City things are going really
well so um and that's because the
ukrainians are resilient and courageous
yeah and we hope to get as much as we
can from the United States to be
resilient courageous for as long as we
can so we're really grateful for that
pivoting to your professional and
political background you're often
described as one of the most prominent
uh behind the scenes voices um in the
Republican party for Ukraine and I've
actually had a very interesting story
with somebody that I deeply Admire from
the Republican Party um I was visiting
DC during the same exchange year when I
was in Louisiana and um I very
accidentally ran into John McCain way he
was actually going to a hearing on
Ukraine caring in Louisiana no no no
sorry in in DC when I was I was I was
staying in Louisiana but then I traveled
to DC for like a short uh program there
and we got to visit actually uh the
United States Congress and to hear these
public hearings because we were like so
amazed while this is so open and we
actually can sort of like firsthand see
the US democracy at uh at play and John
McCain was rushing to a hearing on
Ukraine he was carrying an image of
Ukrainian political prisoner in Russia
at that time and that's how I sort of
like recognized like oh it's something
that has to do with us um and at first I
didn't actually recognize him but then I
it kind of like struck me and I sort of
like said hi I'm from Kev Ukraine and
I'm really grateful for your support um
and at that time time he was sort of
like the embodiment of the Republican
party like the greatest sort of
principal presidential candidate in 2008
yeah and values that
uh I thought it represented and the way
he understood foreign policy and
specifically policy in Russia and
Ukraine was pretty remarkable back then
because uh lots of lawmakers it felt
like didn't that's why Crimea and other
things happened without uh essentially
response but today we see very different
I guess actors in the Republican party
that have little to almost like no
understanding of foreign policy
MGT um other people who are uh very
actively Advocate against support of
Ukraine so I wonder as an Insider I
guess um how do you deal with that
divide inside
yeah well again um there's people in
Congress and more importantly there's
people outside of Congress um I don't
know if you ever heard of the Heritage
Foundation uh yes I did so the Heritage
Foundation is a big little think tank is
what they've uh build themselves as but
they're not really thinking anymore and
uh what they're doing is they're pushing
really dangerous policies by Meme and
you know at one time they had a lot of
people that were really doing good
foreign policy work and and and they
were really concerned about the national
debt and uh and they would push out
these really detailed uh insightful
papers and
now they've replaced all those people
with um people that knows how to use Tik
Tok really well and these folks are
going after uh the 25 billion request
for additional Aid to Ukraine and it's
really dangerous the rhetoric they're
using is really Danger dangerous because
um they're trying to undermine the
Coalition that is supporting Ukraine and
someone has to stand up to these people
and you know I'm one of the people doing
it and someone needs to stand up to the
Heritage foundation's dangerous rhetoric
that is trying to undermine the
Coalition of of international support
that is helping Cape Ukraine free and
and if they're successful in undermining
this Coalition the world becomes a less
safe place um it will embolden XI Jin
ping to um go into Taiwan because if the
if the Coalition that is supporting
Ukraine evaporates after 18 to 24 months
Xi Jinping looks at that and he's like I
can make that deal you know if all I all
I got to do is after I I invade Taiwan
all I got to do is wait two years and
the world forget about it let's send the
Jets so um
um so you know I'm one guy um with a
small NGO but I'm telling everyone who
will listen that folks like the Heritage
Foundation folks like Tucker Carlson do
not represent the the Republican party
not only that they don't represent good
foreign
policy yeah that's good to hear that we
have people W you there as well one of
the many arguments that these anti-
Ukraine I guess anti ERS uh use is that
oh we don't know where the money is
going like we've heard it many times uh
from some of these actors and pretty
high up lawmakers in DC and you've said
multiple times that actually the AIDS to
Ukraine and is one of the best use of
your tax money can you elaborate on that
yeah this is actually really easy and
anybody that says that they're worried
about the where the the money is going
they're worried about where the weapons
are going is not really thinking this
out very well because um we've spent
about $48 billion in weapons and
security uh measures for Ukraine that's
over two years this year the US
Department of Defense will
spend $800
billion $800 billion and a Ukraine is an
amount equal to about 3% of that and for
that money Ukraine has taken back 87% of
its land that Ukraine is now in control
of 87% of its land um and the UK
Ministry of Defense estimates that
Putin's War fighting capability has been
degraded by half now the US Department
of Defense has been spending you know on
the scale of $800 billion a year for
decades in part to deter Russia and they
haven't deterred Russia because Russia's
gone into Georgia they've there's Chia
back in the day there was was uh you
know Ukraine twice Syria yeah yeah Syria
yeah and so this is the most effective
money we have spent to deter Russia and
so on the face of it it's money well
spent and if there's you know look if
there's some you know it's a war if some
of the money is misspent these things
happen but the result of
3% of the budget of the US Department of
Defense has been degrading Putin's War
fighting capabilities by half yeah it's
actually my favorite thing is when I see
sometimes people saying like oh my gosh
like these people in K are partying
where my money are going like how are
they being spent and I'm like but this
is the the biggest proof that your money
are being well spent because just as you
say in March of 2022 nobody was partying
in K because things in K were very very
difficult but ukrainians were able to
fight back with the help of United
States specifically and right now people
people in ke and and other uh liberated
places like I come from a village
outside of ke that was occupied and now
I'm able to go back and see my family
again and see my home again uh so this
is the biggest proof I think that the
money are going to the place that it
needs to be keev is functioning well it
wasn't last year um and nobody's
partying in meletop no one's partying in
Mary opal uh you know donet uh you it's
a really tough neighborhood so there's a
lot of Ukraine where people are being
tortured and abused every day by the
Russians and it is a testament to the
partnership between the US and Ukraine
to degrade the war fighting capabilities
of one of America's biggest adversaries
for decades um it is a testament to that
partnership that things are going well
in keev and you know and and I tell
people the United States the that the
ukrainians view this as a partnership
it's you know the the US and Europe and
Japan and other places are providing the
weapons and Ukraine is providing the
lives of their very best people another
thing that we hear right now in the GOP
specifically but uh in a lot of allies
in Europe and the United States is the
topic of Ukrainian elections during the
war um as we know Ukrainian Constitution
specifically prohibits um conducting
elections during an active War uh
because of different um economic and
other challenges um and Security
challeng even ensuring that um it's
everybody can vote from the refugees
across the world to people in the
trenches who are defending our country
it's a big challenge uh but I know that
even within the Republican Party even
those who really really support um
Ukraine are kind of on the verge on this
topic and our partners at aora
organization ations who are actually um
a leading non-governmental and
nonpartisan Ukrainian organizations that
um overviews the democratic election
process uh they actually conducted
research uh looking at this narrative
about the UK the Ukrainian elections in
the United States and how some people
use it specifically to uh undermine the
support I'm curious what's your personal
opinion on this topic or maybe how do
you um hear about it your circles yeah
good question um frankly not any not
nobody's really talking about the
elections in Ukraine right now among my
circles in in in on Capitol Hill we're
talking about about the US
elections um uh but you know there's
there's certainly a lot of narratives uh
out there one of the things that people
talk about is zilinsky is persecuting
Christians which is nonsense uh and uh
you know the and what's happened is the
Russians have taken the narrative of
arresting Russian Orthodox priests who
are spying for the Kremlin and saying
that's a persecution of Christians and
again it's just nonsense you don't even
have to like dig real deep on that one
yeah yeah so this is a tough time to
have elections um and I don't know
whether it is a good time to have
elections um I think that's kind of up
to the Ukrainian people to decide uh it
is on the one hand um elections are by
their nature divisive and is this a time
to have a uh a lot of divisive Rec
rhetoric internal to Ukraine um and on
the other hand this is a democracy
people want to vote people want to
express their opinion I don't have a
good answer to it how do you feel about
the upcoming US elections yeah there's a
really interesting group of of
Republican candidates um there's a lot
of really good people up there um Tim
Scott is someone I know pretty well I
helped him in his his first ever
election to the USS Representatives uh
really good human Nikki Haley uh I've
met her a couple of times I have a lot
of friends that know her well uh and I
thought she just really took the stage
at this last debate um on Ukraine
specifically yeah yeah so uh so
she if you want a foreign policy
candidate she's it she's great Mike
Pence also did well in Ukraine um Chris
fun because he'll never win but he just
goes after Donald Trump at every
opportunity and here is uh Vivic Robin
Swami is a new
name and I stayed up till 6: am to watch
these these debates here in Kei and I
thought Vivic ramaswami was I don't know
if this translates well into Ukraine but
but for me for Americans like you're in
eighth grade you're like 14 years old
and there's always some kid that's like
pick me I know the the answer pick me I
know the answer that was Vivic ramaswami
on these debates and you know he was
childish to the point of being
cartoonish and he is overeager and
unknowledgeable certainly on Ukraine uh
you know he's like I know the answer but
he didn't know the answer he did not
know much about Ukraine at all you know
like uh and so hopefully um you know I
see someone him as someone that is like
has his day in the Sun and then it
crashes hard so hopefully he takes his
anti Ukraine narrative and crashes hard
with it um so but in general um again
there's organizations and there's forces
in the United States that are trying to
inject Ukraine into the national debate
for you know for the Republicans and
it's not helpful because it's not
accurate um people that are worried
about the national debt are worried
about $25 billion that's going to be
voted on in October which is 3/10 of 1%
% of the national budget 310 you know
whereas if you look at the covid
spending over the last several years
that is twice of what we're spending
this year we're going to spend $6.9
trillion that's what they're what
they're voting on um covid spending is
like $15
trillion but no one's talking about that
they're talking about this $25 billion
doll for Ukraine so why you know I think
Russian propaganda is effective yeah and
it's really disappointing because
sometimes you you hear these arguments
and you feel like do people not
understand that you can't really help
the internal problems with like poverty
or other things with like Javelin
missiles and things those things don't
really yeah you know um I would say this
America does have problems with the
southern border and if we want to start
using howitzers there that's a
conversation we need to have as a nation
otherwise we could probably send them to
Ukraine yeah I I yeah I I think that
that would be a more reasonable decision
um and we definitely can put them to a
way better use for better cause and um I
think also that it's very interesting to
ask you as a policy maker uh or somebody
from that background uh on the question
of sanctions against Russia yeah um we
see that despite uh pretty heavy
sanctions Russian economy is still sort
of striving and not only that but also
according to um the KC KF School of
Economics research on the western
components in the Russian missiles and
other War um equipment we see that a lot
of these Western produced microchips uh
semi conductors are ending up in the
hands of Russians um even 2023 and being
used then to effectively kill ukrainians
um how do you think or is is it possible
even to um enforce better system of
sanctions and prevent that from
happening that is an excellent question
and there's several hundred uh us and
even more International corporations
they're still doing business in Russia
um I don't drink Red Bull anymore um I
used to drink sugar free all the time uh
and Gillette razors um they Proctor and
Gamble is a very preachy company they
want to make sure their consumers of
their products um are indoctrinated with
their values but um they still have two
very large man manufacturing plants in
Russia um Gillette
razors the biggest manufacturing
facility of Gillette razors is in St
Petersburg so there's that right so um
there needs to be the same level of
outrage uh from Americans about
companies doing business in uh Russia
that there is among other social issues
I would like to see that
and to your point about evading
sanctions and microchips do you know the
country in Europe that is the most
prolific by a lot in in getting these
things into Russia getting microchips
and that sort of thing I'm not sure but
I would guess hungry yeah good guess
right around the corner Switzerland
Switzerland Switzerland okay that would
be second guess yeah so uh Kyle Parker
not a household name but he has probably
done more um against Russia than almost
anyone else uh Bill Brower you know that
name so Bill Browder has a book called
red notice the short story about Bill
Browder is that he was a American
businessman started in Russia in like
the90s did a lot of foreign investment
there built a big business and and made
a lot of money in Russia and at some
point 10 years ago or so he got in
Putin's crosshairs and Putin killed one
of his business partners again a
magnitsky so Browder stopped being a
businessman and
became a public policy entrepreneur and
uh Kyle Parker is the legislative
staffer who wrote the legislation called
the magnitsky act that enables the
pinpoint sanctioning of certain
individuals in in places like Russia
that are doing terrible things and uh
and so uh Kyle Parker's wife is from
harv and so Kyle is thinking about
sanctions that can help Ukraine every
day and uh I would encourage uh anyone
to follow him at at at Cal Parker uh at
uh maybe at KY Parker net on Twitter uh
Helsinki commission is the organization
he works for um but last time I was in
DC there was a hearing on Switzerland
Switzerland by far gets the most illegal
stuff into Russia and they have $48
billion it's estimated of Russian assets
uh in their control from oligarchs and
that sort of thing and seven of it is
has been frozen and they want and they
are working to give it back and so the
the Swiss say they're neutral but
they're not they're not they're making a
ton of money off of sanctions on Russia
how do you think we can collectively
especially as I guess like consumers
people um
create this bus around specifically
these Brands like Gillette Proctor
gamble uh to make sure that people are
aware about this happening but also that
they care and they understand that them
buying and supporting this companies
effectively non-directly but still
supports the Russian war machine yeah no
um Proctor and Campell make no mistake
has has put at least $5 million in taxes
uh and that that was in 2022 into the
Russian coffers how much is a caliber
missile you know how much is a uh uh
shahad drone right 20,000 yeah how many
shahad drones did proor and Campbell buy
um so you know again I think it is just
keeping the pressure on if folks just do
that every day you know and remind uh
you know remind the folks that tweet at
Proctor and Gamble tweet it at whoever
else you know about their bad behavior I
think it
helps yes as Russia trying to circumvent
sanctions and doing it very effectively
and keeping up their military Arsenal
there are a lot of conversations in
Ukraine that we're also should be doing
that and not just like relying on the
support of Partners but specifically
investing into the military industry
here um uh investing in a sense also um
getting private donors possibly
interested in in this uh industry
military Tech is a new kind of
attractive topic here to what are your
thoughts on that are you familiar with
this um I have two thoughts one is I am
aware of a huge amount of pent up demand
from investors in the United States into
Ukraine uh and a lot of it is around the
military Tech because um nobody has more
experience now in making weapons uh
to and and using weapons to fight a what
we call in America a near-pure adversary
like Russia and um and so the ukrainians
are becoming the best soldiers in the
world and people want to be a part of
that investors want to be a part of that
and what's holding them back is the fear
of corruption corruption takes a lot of
forms and I think there needs to be a
zero tolerance uh for corruption among
the Ukrainian people um and you know and
don't take part in even small corruption
uh and when you see big corruption make
noise
because Ukraine is is at an inflection
point right now and you know there's a
path that Ukraine can take it can take
the path that gets lots of foreign
investment and that creates a brilliant
future for Ukraine or it can keep going
down the same path where it's commonly
known as one of the most corrupt
countries in the world and I think there
is hope for Ukraine on the corruption
front because I talk to soldiers at the
front I say um have you seen any
corruption around American weapons cuz I
I want to go back you know I want to
find out right so I want to go tell my
friends and the answer is always some
variation on no I have not seen
corruption and if I did I would shoot
that
person and I talk to ukrainians on the
street you know what do you think about
corruption you know and they say things
like too many people have died we're not
going back to the old ways so I see a
real hope for Ukraine because the
Ukrainian people are no longer
tolerating what has beenen Happening
Here for so long but we're
not out of the woods yet you know if the
war's over and everyone kind of goes
back to you know doing what they're
doing and there's still people using the
old ways you know you hear about it and
um so I think the Ukrainian people need
to you know if if there's an activism
that needs to take place that the
Ukrainian people can be most powerful in
um it is internally and
driving out corruption yes I think
actually that the fact that these uh
corruption scandals coming out and
people actually talking about them uh
Publications are writing about them and
activists in Ukraine are being very
vocal and also producing that
information not only in Ukrainian but
also in English is actually um a
testament to the fact that ukrainians
are fighting it I would agree and what
what's difficult for people abroad to
recognize is is that um one um a Supreme
Court justice was just you know was just
taken out for corruption right that's
bad news the good news is a Supreme
Court justice was just taken out for
corruption right you know I I talked to
friends are like you know 10 years ago 5
years ago we never would have thought
that would happen and I think that's the
message that needs to get out I think
the Ukrainian people need to have a zero
tolerance policy and then they need to
get that message out yeah and uh I think
it's uh it's it's in the best interest
of us to do that obviously to Foster the
trust um of the foreign part partners
and as you said corruption takes many
forms it happens in many places
obviously um it's kind of sad that this
part of the world is notoriously known
for that um and we always talk about
this and analyze sort of in historic way
where it's coming from and if you look
at the history of corruption is coming
from kind of the Russian way of dealing
with things because that country
literally functions on corruption basis
and uh obviously that country had a lot
of um influence on still Generations
that are currently living in Ukraine and
uh taking up these positions but
hopefully uh we can see that the young
people are really as you say kind of
zero tolerance uh stands on corruption
yeah um when we talk about the future of
Ukraine we often say that it's literally
being decided right now on the
battlefield but uh when it comes to
things like corruption and other like
policies uh we understand that it's also
important to not Overlook other spheres
of um the development of the country the
progress and I'm curious just to like
talk to somebody who's not Ukrainian how
do you see Ukraine after Victory
obviously Victory can take many forms so
uh maybe that's not the question it's
more like how do you see Ukraine both
internally and on the international
Arena that is a good question um this
war has obviously been horrible on a
number of levels um and Ukraine has lost
a lot of really good people um
and the good news about this war is that
in January of 2022 you know um probably
like 7% of Americans could point to
Ukraine on a map now everyone knows
about Ukraine and I think the great news
about Ukraine is things like you know
the it sector has grown dramatically uh
in during the war and it's still is
Ukraine is home to so many smart people
smart creative Innovative people and I
think that is a story that's getting out
and I think that Ukraine has the
potential to be like the next
big it place right I mean like Silicon
Valley East right and it's got the human
capital um you know the people the
people are I mean the people here work
hard and the people here are Innovative
and the people um you know my Ukrainian
friend I took to the United States said
that uh you know the US is so much like
Ukraine because it's you know they value
freedom and they're entrepreneurial and
they're innovative and that's the way
she uh saw the the two cultures aligning
and I think that's true and you know
what you need is uh governance that
matches that and helps that grow and I
think you'll get there because again I
just remember this thing young woman I
met on the street I didn't even know her
name and never talked to her again I was
just talking to her about it and she
said uh she said you know we're not
going back to the old ways too many
people people have died and I think
that's something that is shared by
ukrainians and certainly people under 35
or so and uh so I think that uh yeah I
think that I'm super hopeful I'm here
man you know I live here by choice um so
uh you know I could be in the United
States right now um you know I'm a
volunteer I I could be in the United
States having a good job and making a
lot of money and you know watching
Netflix every night um and uh in a nice
apartment but I'm here and you know why
because I have faith in the Ukrainian
people and I want to be a part of what's
going on here yeah I guess watching um a
TV show on Netflix a history TV show is
not that interesting as actually
watching The Real History Happening Here
in Ukraine so I'm glad that you're
choosing to do that um lastly I wanted
to ask you what's your favorite place in
Ukraine good question um
I was just recently in the carpathians
really nice really enjoyed that it's a
beautiful part of the world um so that's
really nice um ke you know like right
here where we are you know is this is
nice uh you know here's what I like
about ke is that you can walk everywhere
and there's places to walk and people
are out and there's interesting people
doing interesting things on the street
you know you've got Street artists
you've got um you know like you there's
people like playing the cello just
beautiful cello music really talented
musicians just being outside and ke and
walking around um just the vibe the
energy and the beauty and the history
and you know what's not to like about ke
except for the occasional missile that's
true but hopefully that will stop um
sooner than later is there something
that you've learned about um Ukrainian
culture that maybe you've been mistaken
for like Russian culture before
and now that you live here actually
you're oh yeah yellow blue b yellow
blue uh yeah I don't even like beats uh
but I like them in borch I mean yeah how
do you not like
borch um yeah you know I'm learning
Ukrainian um hu capuccino
zias oh I'm also Leos and to in yeah in
case you are so I say the same thing
yeah and uh uh yeah so um you know I've
come to appreciate uh a lot of the
things um you know I tell my friends
it's like you know teras chevchenko is
like Ukraine's George Washington he's a
poet and they're kind of like you know I
wish they had more Heroes that killed
people you know so uh but you know I I
like the poet culture you know I mean
there's all these great poets that that
uh that things are named after and uh um
so I don't know if you've seen that
we're erasing the Russian points and all
of those people from the street names
the city names and other things because
it's a really important effort in order
to diversify the country no I thought
you know someone said why are they
spending the money on taking the hammer
and sickle off of the motherland statue
you know and I was like seems like a
good idea to me um let's completely
erase Russian and Soviet influence from
Ukraine because that's kind part of the
narrative oh Ukraine's really part of
Russia no no it's not um there's a great
book The Gates of Europe yes so fing
yeah that guy's awesome I read that book
and you know and and like that book
every chapter is the answer to answers
the question and this is why Ukraine is
an independent country you know and uh
and so that was a really interesting
book love that book yeah everybody
should read the book if you're
interested in Ukraine and understanding
why it's not a part of Russia and why
it's fighting so fiercely well thank you
so much for joining us today it was
really interesting to talk to and hear
your insights and thank you for your
volunteering and for your valuable work
in helping Ukraine both I guess in D DC
and here in inside the country let me
just add um I got to do some
self-promotion here so uh folks can
follow me on Twitter I'm on Ukraine
Freedom 7 on Twitter Instagram
Ukraine Freedom Pro follow me on
Instagram and my website is Ukraine
Freedom project.org follow me on Twitter
send me a message uh follow me on
Instagram you know love hear from people
you were watching Ukraine in English and
our series Ukraine Through The Eyes of
others where we're joined by Steve Moore
thank you so much for coming today and
please follow ukrainer in English on
YouTube uh comment if you really uh
found this video insightful and we're
going to be back with new guests thank
[Music]
you